so huge disappointment everyone it's not
Xavier okay I guess okay all right are
you ready Josh yes you're waiting my
plane - yeah here you go here's the
other controller me dude I'm scared
wait am i skip Wescott yeah are you
ready I'm not comfortable I'm gonna tilt
the left eye I made this specifically
for this stream just because I thought
it would be funny and also kind of
[ __ ] up I threw this spider-man
character model together in like two
hours before we started doing this I was
just making photos look okay so it looks
like his bellybutton is just the webbing
oh yeah I don't like okay I did the best
I could so I have no idea what he's
doing
right now that fit Peter at all he's a
very regal spider-man obviously oh
someone else said it
what's wrong with spider-man's face I'm
not the only one I II tried to fix it I
again I threw it together very quickly
oh god I'm going to hell for this is
everyone ready
it's it's the greatest spider-man
villain oh I think like ten minutes ago
I found a website dedicated to skip
Westcott there's really weird it's
really oddly ultra specific I didn't
like it I thought it was old - as like
only HTML stuff like like no no no CSS
it wasn't like pretty it'll who's just
gross oh god he's here Peter this is the
rematch okay all right I don't know how
to play this game you can't just do this
it's time I get my revenge
more powerful than I thought I
immediately am getting my ass kicked I'm
too traumatized with fear and sadness I
also made sure that all of skips moves
involve grabbing or grabbing crotches
you're not gonna doodle any more
children on my watch
Steven oh it's brick oh yeah yeah
you can't diddle with that arm anymore
skip I'm gonna win I got up it's okay no
it's not okay
you're part of my origin story that they
emit from the rest of the Canon don't
turn me around Xavier please it's time
for some retribution
turn around skip suplex oh come on you
can't get behind me anymore skip I have
spider sense for that are you gonna give
up yet skip I can't get up so I think so
yeah that's right Oh truffle butter man
wins yeah take that childhood trauma
I've overcome my fear okay Night Watch
is a guy who was going to college right
but then a guy dressed his Nightwatch
came in from the future and he died but
then he pulled the suit off of him and
was like this guy looks like me but way
older he even has the same birthmark on
his check on his chest and he has a
laser gauntlet and then there's a gang
war in New York and then gets tired
physically exhausted why can't
spider-man get married he's too clingy
whoever said that you you win a prize no
prize
I hear that bomb squad joke quite often
and I gotta tell you it just never loses
its luster no matter how many times I
hear it
yes always funny it's always funny every
time
let's have Master Chief involved and
and who else my uncle will have my uncle
here yeah hell yeah I'm viola and then
we'll have again you wouldn't beat up a
lot of blind man would you yes I will
well what's your Instagram Xavier use
Instagram constantly right that's your
daily actual media I don't have that
but I have a Twitter you follow me there
he forced me to make a Twitter to follow
him I mean I should have turned
notifications off before we do I was in
a spider-man ps4 reaction video but oh
yeah either spider-man ps4 reaction
video that was Josh sitting next to me
the Master Chief looks like a GI Joe
tried my best I mean it looks okay
it's with it it's like you know when
people complain about old graphics from
like 1990 it's like dude we limitation
plus if I turn that in for a school
project I mean I I don't want to beat up
Miles Morales I think okay everyone
leave Myles alone just give him oh give
him a rest he has to deal with being
written by Bendis all day he has a hard
time as it is just cut the kid a break
okay he has to keep having Yiddish slang
terms thrown into all of his dialogue
regardless of it making sense
look it's my uncle that's really weird
creating my uncle I even remade an
actual shirt that he wears ah I'm
dropping bits and pieces of pizza
what is this cruel timeline oh [ __ ] Oh
what's happening I got which one I was
playing as okay I'm spider-man my hand
is not clean how do I get up on this
rope all right I'm just gonna perch up
here like I do in 2099 your voices don't
match the way you look I hope to god
they don't fly ever start up a YouTube
channel I'm not I'm not showing my face
it's too late you've already shown your
face on myutils consistently people who
I'm just gonna ride one out I'm gonna
press Y all over you which one are you
kids I think a watch man oh let me I
latched on that broke right there so I
wouldn't fall that the name of that
character is an inside joke just to piss
off my friend Jackson because he said
something silly like one since in like
seventh grade I have never let it and
let him live it down
I'm just gonna perch up here and wait
this is what the real Miguel O'Hara
would do way notice the costume is black
what's haha birds your uncle looks like
a gay Bob Marley what gives away and
he's home oh I can't tell skinny jeans
alright we're down one Super Soldier
Spartan okay okay that never happened
before in the entire time I've owned
this game is why that what why why
daredevil stop it I seem to have flipped
you over somehow Wyatt my ass this might
ah
get up Miguel I'm so confused in danger
future okay the name Godzilla Mendoza um
when my parents were in the process of
naming me they just came up with all
kinds of dumb [ __ ] and my dad was
like what if we named him Godzilla and
my mom was like no that's a terrible
idea let's name him after my favorite
x-men character and I always keep it as
like a memento of the life I could have
had cuz could you imagine if my name was
actually Godzilla Mendoza I could never
get in trouble at school because the
teacher wouldn't be physically capable
of yelling damn it Godzilla a great
singer but an awful fighter well yeah
bruised dead oh I didn't notice all
right Miguel's on top once again it's
time I take back New York 2099 Miguel's
costume from the comics and the 90s are
better than his new one his new one
looks silly because it has like white
slippers on it help me Lila or someone
come in Lila I need you to send the
Avengers to my location
you know Miguel O'Hara's capable of
lifting Thor's hammer because he's
worthy and he also kills people cuz you
have to be both
get your ass back down over that ledge
don't come over here
okay with our powers combined we can
beat up this blind lawyers actually like
we beat each other up
damn this is like this without kicking
me it's like a Three Stooges racin I got
it I got it
hold on I'm about to signature yep get
up behind him like pretend you're skip
but make sure you don't oh [ __ ]
I'm dead I'm sorry it's just me now wait
no no oh god no help no I did it I did
it by sucker punching him in the crotch
Chris yeah hell yeah you used all this
audio and make creepy parodies on uh-oh
oh boy
Oh make creepy parodies on Newgrounds
hey Xavier
what was your GPA in high school I don't
know probably really bad my attendance
was awful people kept theorizing that I
died because I showed up to school so
little I was freaking out - I was one of
the first people like the senior year I
missed it like a month and a half of
school
[Music]
[Laughter]
these bullshit's I did not hit her I did
not have no okay well I could just kill
the video don't wait on someone enjoys
your existence oh thanks I also somewhat
enjoy my existence yeah take that small
child you're like 15 I'm beating the
[ __ ] out who's your favorite porn star
Xavier I don't know the names of any hey
Edward oh that's a pretty nice jacket I
bet it cost you an arm and a leg
how's a good one is really Savior who is
your favorite hentai babe that is most
definitely how the [ __ ] we possibly know
the name of war ring tosaka babe I don't
know you're the best
I can't remember the names of the
hottest what gosh I can't remember the
names of non-porn anime characters like
I remember Edward Elric because it's
easy this this stream might imply that I
like anime I have watched one and it's
this one Full Metal Alchemist is England
a city uh yeah it's my city
[ __ ] hell I did it do it
you just broke my heart I didn't do
anything I can't break your arm it's
made of metal did I finish oh I did the
path it's okay I'm a big strong man with
a healing factor I can please stop help
ah how's the merch selling you making
merch and selling no didn't think so I
would like to yeah we were talking about
that I thought I know about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Chito be butterfly Uncle Ben Tobey
Maguire's should totally play about that
but I would be such an amazing to call
back favorite superhero movie favorite
superhero movie um oh yeah yeah there's
a lot of them I really like um I'll also
try to answer
okay how did you set the finishers doing
phonetics edited why do I keep
forgetting to do that by myself no I'm
getting my ass kicked because I keep not
doing that Christopher Daniel Barnes or
Josh Keaton Josh Keaton although
Christopher Daniel Barnes
he was a great Miguel voice later on in
time
ah my Deadpool Sami I could just mash
why and you can't do anything he's
kicking my weight this game honestly I
okay I'm actually gonna genuinely
research this this this game is actually
making me mad cuz it's about stuff he's
already dead [ __ ] I don't get it
that was super one-sided I know like
just make it easy it's because I picked
a real character you were a real
wrestler who had actual moves uh
favorite super gun favorite super
villain venom weird spider Wasco spider
would come out Oh someone did ask okay
if you watched porn I'll answer that
with like just the ref in the crop okay
sorry
okay um I'll answer that question with
another question is uh is one more day
really awesome spider-man villains on a
skill in one to ten that's that's a lot
of stuff uh Wow electro is a solid seven
although Doc Ock is maybe a five for me
just because superior and then for the
lizard maybe a four he seems to not
really have a whole lot going on it's a
really repetitive character art the
vulture I would definitely say is maybe
closer to an eight I definitely enjoy
his part in Marvel Knights spider like
do you do you really want me to do all
of them I'd be a lot that'd be a lot cuz
I know more than like most people I can
name off the obscure ones but I can't
like willow the wisp ah come on I'm
having such a bad day you guys I keep
falling out of the ring
I like it back in I don't actually have
no idea here let me just there we go I
did ate you up no stop please Big Show
test stream is everyone bored yet
yeah are you guys it's mostly just so
sorry this is so been proposed it's
really I mean yeah I'm enjoying myself
too I know that we enjoy ourselves I
don't want to bore half the audience
okay Xavier do you prefer Andrew or Tom
dude Oh Tom Tom Tom but part of the room
[Music]
[Music]